XAVIER DUCROHET: Good morning.
My name is Xavier Ducrohet.
I'm the lead for the Android
SDK developer tools.
And I'm the main contributor
to the new build
system for the SDK.
So why a new build system?
Well, if you look at the current
situation, on one
hand, we have some end scripts
that are somewhat
customizable, although we have
no public API for it, and it's
likely to break whenever
we update the SDK.
On the other hand, we have ADT
custom builders, very rigid,
but at least it works
in the IDE.
And then we have [INAUDIBLE]
that has its own builder.
It's a bit more flexible, but
it doesn't do many fast
merging, some issues.
So we want to fix that.
We wanted to create a single
build system that was very
flexible so that it adapts
to all of your
needs, within reasons.
And we wanted that build system
to work whether you're
building from your continuous
integration server
or within the IDE.
If your customization doesn't
work in your IDE, then it just
doesn't work.
It breaks your workflow.
We wanted to add some features,
like dependency
management, the ability to
deploy and run tests, but also
Android-specific features that
developers have asked us.
We didn't want to start
from scratch.
So we looked around.
There's a lot of build
systems out there.
They have plug-in ecosystem,
support in Jenkins, TeamCity,
and we wanted to leverage
all of that.
So we looked around, and
we settled on Gradle.
So why Gradle?
Well, as a user, it's
very powerful,
great declarative syntax.
But you can customize to your
need, and it has a great
tooling API to do
IDE integration.
From our point of view, when we
develop the plugin, we can
create a new domain-specific
language to really make the
configuration of the
build system
very specific to Android.
We can expose great
APIs for you to
extend the build system.
And the IDE integration can be
customized so that the IDE
really knows not just about,
hey, just some sort of build
system, but it's really an
Android Build System.
It's also developed by a company
called Gradleware who
designed open source.
It's Apache, so that's
great for us.
And we've worked together to
make sure that the build
system Gradle itself is adding
features, specifically, that
we need so that we can give the
best possible experience
to you developers.
So I figure that a lot of you
probably don't know Gradle, or
maybe just tried it
a little bit.
So I wanted to start with some
basics and go through some
simple projects.
So if you look at a very simple
Java project, first the
configuration is in a file
called build.gradle that's
located at the root of your
project, where you would find
your build.xml, or pom.xml
if you build
it with Ant or Maven.
So with a simple line, what you
can do is build your main
code and generate the JAR file,
build your test code,
run your test, and get to output
some XML file that you
can feed into your Jenkins
server to get some trends and
dashboard, and a local HTML
report to get the same result
when you're running your test
on your workstation.
The same Android project is a
little bit more complicated,
but it's not that bad, really.
So the first section of the
build script is about telling
Gradle where our plugin is.
So we're saying here, hey
it's on mavenCentral.
Here's the artifact.
Just put it on the class path.
It's something that the Gradle
developer wants to improve the
future, so hopefully it will
be a bit less verbose.
So we just apply the
plugin like we did
for the Java plugin.
And then the third block is
really the beginning of the
configuration of the
Android plugin.
And so we have two
properties here.
The first one, compileSdkVersion
is what
you'd use as target in
project.properties.
We renamed it because target,
target SDK version, there was
some confusion there.
And then the second property
I will talk about later.
So what can you do with that?
Well, you can build an APK.
We can build a test APK.
It used to be that we had
a separate test project.
It's just not flexible.
We have to find it.
It's so hard to find
the relation
between the two projects.
So it's back in the
main project.
You can deploy those two APKs
and run the test on any number
of connected devices.
It will run them in parallel,
and you'll get the same two
output-- the XML and the HTML.
So already, we do more
than the Ant script.
So as you noticed, I didn't
configure anything.
It's convention over
configuration.
And for source folder, this is
the convention for regular
Java projects, because you
have your main code
and your test code.
It's in the source main
and source test.
So for Android, we reuse
the same convention.
We expand it a little
bit, because we
have a lot more files.
So source main, we add Android
manifest, XML.
We add the resources,
the assets.
We move the AID and run
the scripts files
under their own folders.
And then, on the test side, we
call that instrument test.
We wanted to keep test for
actual true local [? JUnit ?]
test.
We don't have a manifest
in there.
It will be automatically
generated.
I'll talk about that later.
All right, so that's
your structure.
Now, how do you run the thing?
Oh wait, hold on.
So if you have an old project,
I'm guessing that you probably
don't want to go back to all
of that and change your
project just to try Gradle.
So this is how you configure a
project that you currently
have to tell Gradle this
is my structure.
So here's it's very simple.
Again, in the Android block,
we have a sourceSet.
And that's a container
of sourceSet.
And so, inside, we configure
the main and
the instrument test.
So for our instrument test, what
we do is that setRoot.
We'll just move everything from
source/instrumentTest to test.
So test/Java, test/res
et cetera.
Notice how, for the main
source sets, we have
res.srcDirs.
And it's actually a [INAUDIBLE]
with bracket.
That's because we can
actually now support
multiple res folders.
So you can just organize your
source however you want them,
and then we just merge them
together, detect duplicates,
and do the right thing.
All right, so to run Gradle.
Well, once you have installed
Gradle, you go to your project
root, and you just do Gradle
and some task name.
To get the task, there's a task
called task that give you
the list of tasks.
And if you do dash dash all,
it will give you all the
intermediate tasks that you
probably don't care about.
And on the really complicated
project, it's going to be 50
tasks, or something like that.
You don't care about
all of those.
You care about four of them.
assemble will build your
project output.
Check will run all your
checked and test.
Build will do both assembling
and testing.
This is what buildling
a product is.
It's building it, but
also testing it.
And then clean does the clean.
So the thing that's interesting
here is that those
tasks actually don't
do anything.
I like to call them
anchor tasks.
Plugins will go and kind of like
plug them under it, and
say, hey, when the users says
assemble, here's the task that
you should actually call.
So the Java project,
for instance,
has different tasks--
JAR to build the JAR, and
test to run the test.
So that means that when you
apply some other plugin like
the [INAUDIBLE], there's a
FindBug plugin, you don't have
to care what it's tasks are.
You just call check, and it will
call test, FindBugs main
and FindBugs test.
So it's very powerful and very
extensible without you having
to know what's going on
So for Android, we do
the same thing.
We have assemble, and then we
have check, and then we have
connectedCheck and
deviceCheck.
And this is because of
the test without
device, test with device.
I'll talk about that later.
One of the differences, assemble
will actually build
two different versions.
We have the debug in [INAUDIBLE]
release, similar
to Ant release and debug.
Except that here, you can
actually build both of them in
parallel and have them
built while Ant will
override each other.
All right, so let's talk about
customization a little bit.
That's why we're building
this new build system.
So the most basic customization
is, let's say
you want to override
some properties.
So for example, here we have a
defaultConfig object inside
the Android object that says
hey, I'm going to do version
code and minSdkVersion,
and something.
And so when you build, those
values will get injected into
your manifest and
that's great.
You're probably wondering, well,
why do I want to do that
when I can actually just put
those values in my manifest?
Well, imagine that you want to
do a nightly build where you
want to increase the version
code incrementally.
So you could do some script that
goes in, and somehow hack
your manifest around, and do
something, and that's probably
not very good.
So here, Gradle allow us to just
do something while you
create a new function that will
get that version code
from Jenkins, for example,
through system property or
[INAUDIBLE].
And then you just inject it
into the version code.
And that will work
all the time.
And then, if the function
actually returns minus one by
default, which is when you're
running on your desktop, then
the value will not
be injected.
So you can do some custom logic,
but it's still very
declarative.
I mentioned just a minute
ago that we
built debug and release.
And a lot of developers have
asked us things like, hey, I
want to run ProGaurd in debug.
Can I do that please?
And before it was like,
well we can't redo it.
So we looked at it, and we
said we're going to do
something really flexible.
And so we introduced the
concept of build types.
Build types are about how I
package my application and
some options like, is it
debuggable, how is it signed,
do I run ProGaurd?
And you start with a built-in
debug and a built-in release
one, but you can create
new ones.
So here's the DSL to do it.
So inside the Android
object, you have a
very build types object.
That's also a container.
We saw that.
We saw sets.
We're going to use that again.
It's a typical pattern
that we have.
And so in it, we configure
the debug properties.
And we set some property of
the debug build type.
And we set some properties.
And one of them is package
name suffix.
So any time you build with
debug, whatever the package
name of your application is,
will append the debug at the
end of the package so that you
can study it side by side with
your release application.
And then suffix name will just
a suffix also to extend.
It's something that a lot of
developers have asked us.
And then we have this new thing
in Play Console where
you can have a beta version.
And maybe you want to actually
build a specific beta version
for those testers.
And so you can create
a new beta test.
And so here we are adding
some properties.
And that's great.
But that's not really enough.
You should really want to
customize that beta version.
So for each build type,
you also get a
custom source folders.
So for example, in your beta
version, it's a beta test, so
you want to gather some
statistics on how your users
are using your application.
So how do I do that?
Well, under source/beta/java,
you just put some code.
And that code will get packaged
with your beta
application whenever you build
only the beta version, not the
release, and not the
debug version.
You probably want internet
permission to be able to send
those data.
And maybe your regular
application doesn't have the
internet permission.
So instead of bring it manually
in the manifest some
time and forgetting to remove
it, which is not great, you
just put it in source, beta,
Android manifest, and that
gets merged into your main
manifest when you build only
the beta version.
And you can use that also for
things like if you have
MapView API key and you want a
different API key on release
and debug because it's tied to
you're signing configuration,
well, you can just put that into
the res folder of those
different build types.
And of course, you need
to be able to
build the beta version.
So that's where the assemble
debug and assemble release are
coming from.
They are just automatically
generated whenever you add a
new build type.
So you can actually have all
three versions at the same
time and build them.
All right.
So I just said that signing
was part of the build type
configuration.
So we wanted to make things
very flexible here.
We have a container of signing
configuration.
And a signing configuration is
in a location of the KeyStore,
passwords, you know,
name of the key.
And we have a default version
one called debug.
And so here, what we're doing
in that simple example is we
are telling Gradle, configuring
the debug signing
configuration and using a
KeyStore that's at the root of
my project so that way, everyone
on your team or your
build server always
would build with
the same debug KeyStore.
And there won't be an issue
when your QA is trying to
install something coming
from a different build.
And that's all you have to do.
The debug build type is
automatically configured to
use that particular signing
configuration.
Let's look at another a little
bit more complicated example.
Let's say you have a release
version of your application
that is different from your
debug because maybe you have
some properties that tell it,
hey, I want to use my
production server instead
of some test server.
I'm using ProGuard.
I'm obfuscating and doing
a lot of things.
And I want to test
that version.
I want to debug it.
How do I do that?
Well, what you would do, you
would create a new build type,
call it debug release,
for instance.
InitWith will initialize it with
the release build type.
So every time you go and change
your release build
type, it just gets copied
into your debug release.
And then we customize
something.
So we say, hey, it's
debuggable.
We add a suffix to the package
name to make sure you can set
it in parallel with the
your release version.
And then we assign the debug
signing config so that anyone
can build it.
And then we change the sourceSet
to make sure that
source/release, whatever you put
in there, is also used to
build your debug release.
And just with these few lines,
you suddenly have a new
version of your application
that's exactly, and always
exactly, the same as your
release, but you can debug it.
And if you wanted to have some
custom ProGuard specifically,
also, for that version, to
disable or enable some rules,
you could do that.
But by default, it will just
pick up all the rules that the
version would use.
What I really like about that
example, also, is that it's
not showing you that
it's declarative.
But initWith here doesn't
receive a primitive type.
It receives, actually,
a buildtypes.release.
That's actually an object
of type build type.
So what happens is that every
time inside the build type
container, you start using
release, or debug, or beta, if
that particular object doesn't
exist, we create
a build type instance.
And we put it in
the container.
So what you're really doing
here is not just setting a
bunch of properties that will
be read later on, and by
something that will parse that
file, and build something.
Every line actually manipulates
a live model.
And that's very important
and very powerful.
That means that, let's say we
have the release, beta, debug,
debug release.
That's a lot of them.
And maybe you don't want to put
the suffix for the package
name on all of them manually.
What if you could just
it programmatically?
Well, just do something
like that.
After the Android block, where
you configure all your build
types, just loop on the build
types and just assign
automatically the
package name.
What's really interesting here
is that you're basically
building that model.
And that configured model is
what is sent to the IDE during
the IDE integration when you
report your project.
So whether you're setting those
package name suffixes
manually or whether you're using
some logic, a loop, or
maybe you say, hey, we only want
to add them on Mondays,
whatever you're doing, it's
just going to work.
The IDE will just be aware of
what's going on, because it
gets the final configured
model.
And that's very powerful.
That allows us to really have
the IDE know everything about
your project based
on that model.
However, it is, whatever
logic you use to
actually configure it.
All right, let's look
at dependencies.
It's something that a lot of
developers have asked for.
So Gradle supports that
natively, so we
benefit from that.
So there's four scopes
of dependencies--
compile, runtime, that's for
your main source code.
And runtime always
extends compile.
So if you had a dependency
to compile, runtime
automatically gets it.
And then there's the
same for test.
So far Android, slightly
different, mostly because we
renamed runtime to package,
because it's
what really we do.
We package all of your
dependencies into the APK.
And then test, instrument test,
to make sure that it's
always instrumentation test.
So let's go back to your
beta version, right?
We want to send the statistic
to the user.
Let's say you want to use some
library to help you.
Well, if you add them on
compile, that means that your
release will also have
that library.
And you don't want to do that.
So we have scopes specifically
for your build types.
So here, only on the build type
compile scope, you would
say, hey, I use [INAUDIBLE]
or something like that.
And then it's only for
that build type.
So this is how you do dependency
in Gradle.
You have a dependencies
object.
Compile is the scope.
And then you give it whatever
dependency you have.
Here we say, if I have an old
project and I have a bunch of
JAR filing under my libs
project, that's what you do.
[INAUDIBLE]
every JAR file under libs.
Very useful to migrate
your current project.
So if you want to use
remote dependencies,
this is what you do.
First, you tell it what
repository to use.
So here we say mavenCentral, but
you could say, if you have
a custom internal artifact
repository, you
can put the URL there.
Whether it's Maven or Ivy,
it will support it--
not a problem.
And then in the dependency
block, the instrument test
compile, you give the
artifact address.
And here we use the fest-android
from square that
allow you to have some nice
asserts and test output.
And then notice how the beta
compile use the local JAR.
So it's not I want to use either
dependency management
with Maven or a local JAR
file, you can just mix
depending on what you have.
Gradle is very flexible.
It will use whatever you want.
So that's about using
someone else's code.
If you want to use your own
code, it's slightly different.
First, you need to have
a multi-project setup.
It's something that we
didn't have before.
Eclipse doesn't really support
that, and [INAUDIBLE]
of course.
So here, what we have
is, we have three
different package modules.
There's app, lib1, lib2.
They're all their own project
with their own build.gradle.
And there is settings.gradle
that say, here's all the
different modules.
And for the dependency, you
just say, hey, I want to
include the project and the
path of the project.
So that's very similar
and very easy.
So library 1 could be
a library project.
And then lib2 could be
just like a JAR file.
And if lib1 depend on lib2,
of course, app will get
transitively your
dependencies.
And so if lib1 is a library
project, this is how you
declare a library project.
It's exactly the same as
a regular project.
It's the same plugin.
You only need one plugin.
It has both only one
Maven artifact.
It has both plugins inside.
And the plugin name is
different, but it's exactly
the same as a regular project.
The DSL is slightly different,
because there's some
restrictions.
But I'm not going to go
into detail on that.
So what does a library
project do?
Very similar to what
they currently do.
We have some new things.
The first thing is that,
finally, we have binary
packaging of them.
So we package everything
into an AAR format.
It's just a Zip file.
It's a bundle.
And you can upload that
into repositories.
[APPLAUSE]
XAVIER DUCROHET: Guess it's
been a long time coming.
Other thing that we support, we
had support for assets, so
just put assets in
your library.
They'll get merged into
your application.
We have ProGuard rules.
So if, for example, your library
has some specific
class that should not be
obfuscated, just create a
ProGuard file to say keep
that particular file.
And whenever that application
that use that library runs
ProGuard, it will also enable
that ProGuard rule so that
your class doesn't get
obfuscated, for instance.
We don't have Lint integration
yet, but as soon as add it, we
want to do things like not
custom Lint rules, so that if
you have some custom-made APIs
that you want to make sure
people use properly, you can
have some rules there.
And we are looking at adding
other metadata so that whoever
use your library, they have a
better experience in the tool
chain, in the IDE, and it's
better for your user.
All right, so library project
have been used for people who
want to do free versus paid
and things like that.
And it's great.
Now multiple APK support in
Google Play also allow you to
do, for example, different APK
for if you're targeting an
older version of Android or a
newer version of Android, or
if you're targeting ARM versus
MIPS versus x86.
But if you want to use all three
or a combination, then
it becomes impossible to deal
with library project.
And so we have build variants.
So this concept of product
flavor is about what is your
application?
So it's going to support
different applications,
whether they have the same
package name or not, depending
if free versus paid or not.
And it will do customized
things.
So it's really like a different
dimension from build type.
It's combined with
build types.
So here's how you create them.
We have a product flavor
containers.
And you can just create
new ones.
So here I'm creating two
flavors, flavor1, flavor2.
I'm assigning some packages.
One of them say, hey, I want
a different minSDK version.
The other one will use the
minSDK version from the
manifest automatically.
And of course you want
to have different
code in those, right?
The free version will have
some code specifically to
free, and the paid
version to paid.
So for each of those, you get
a new source folder as well.
And because you want to test
it separately, you get a
separate test folder as well.
And if you have a free version
that's supported by ads, you
want to add some like dependency
on AdMob's SDK, for
instance, but you don't want
to put that on the paid
version as well, so you have
a different scope.
So here, we'll have a lot
of scope for all your
applications.
And basically, based on what you
build, we'll pick all of
them and put all your
dependencies together.
So the part that's important is
that, if you don't have any
flavor, and you have debug and
release build types, you get a
debug and a release
application.
If you have flavors, then it's
really a matrix, and we do a
combination of everything.
So if you have flavor1 and
flavor2, then you can't have
just a debug build.
It doesn't mean anything
anymore.
It's either flavor1 debug
or flavor2 debug.
So that's very useful if you
have flavors to [? spend. ?]
Now, if you also want to combine
x86, versus MIPS and
versus ARM, well, that doesn't
really work, right?
So we have flavor dimensions.
But we called then groups
in the DSL.
We might have to rename that.
So it's really a different
dimension compared to--
so one dimension is ABI,
x86 versus ARM.
And the other one is the
version, whether
it's paid or free.
And so here, we create two ARM,
and we assign them to a
specific dimension.
So note how the ARM1 doesn't
customize the package name.
That's because it's just
the same version of you
application, while the
paid version has
its own package name.
So there's going to be some
combination of all of that.
First, at the end, you get
a lot of packages.
And you just get them
automatically.
And if you add a new dimension
or add something, it will just
take care of generating
all of that for you.
And so, because it's
complicated, you need to
understand all the different
ways we combined all of those
dimensions--
build type and different
dimensions of product flavor.
So you could get up to four
different source folders, for
example, in that particular
example.
And so they're all going to be
considered as if there was
just one source folder.
And we'll just combine
everything into a single SDK.
If you have resources, we just
use override mechanisms.
So we start with your
base resources.
We override on top of
it the flavors.
And then on top of that, we
override the build types.
And that's for res and
for assets as well.
And if you have libraries, they
will be under the main
one, and they will be overridden
by all that.
Signing configuration, here
we have some flexibility.
It's a priority order.
So highest priority order is
build type, and then flavor,
and then your main
configuration.
What's interesting here is that
the debug build type has
the default debug
configuration.
And so every debug build
type will get signed
with the same key.
For release, if you assign a
signing configuration on the
release build type, all your
release will be signed with
the same key.
But if you don't want to do
that-- maybe your paid and
your free needs different
signing key-- then don't
assign a signing configuration
on the build type, and assign
it on the flavor instead.
And then it's the one that will
get picked up, and you
can have different signing
for two different
versions of your apps.
And the package name, so you saw
that we have a lot of ways
of customizing package name.
So we start with the
base Android
package name in the manifest.
If you have a different
configuration that overrides
it, we take this one instead.
If you have a flavor,
we take this one.
And then, when we figure out
which package you have, if you
have one in the build type,
we append the suffix.
But when we generate the R
class, we always use the
package name in the
src/main/AndroidManifest.xml
that so that all of your import,
wherever you are, are
always the same one.
There's no switching.
You can generate many
applications with different
package names.
But all your imports are
always the same.
OK let's talk about testing.
I mentioned testing
here and there, so
let's do a quick recap.
You have source folders for
testing and one per flavor, if
you use flavors.
You have dependency scopes, one
specific for testing and
one per flavors.
We generate the manifests.
And now you probably understand
why we generate
those manifests, since if you
generate six different
applications with six different
packages, you don't
want to maintain six different
manifests for your test
application.
The manifest for the test
application actually reference
the package being tested.
So that would be a
lot to maintain.
And for the package name of
the test application, we
generate that automatically
based on the package name of
the tested application.
And we're going to have one
test app per tested
application.
So right now, we only test
to one build type.
So debug, by default, you
can configure it.
We'll probably change
that in the future.
But right now, it's just one.
And then finally, library
project, even though they
output just an AAR not an
APK, we can test those.
So inside the library
project, one of the
outputs is the test APK.
And it will embed your library
into it, so you can test your
library separately and inside
your APK also, if you want.
All right, so that's
about building.
What about running tests?
So that's a little
bit complicated.
And we looked into it.
And we found out that
there's really
three different scenarios.
The first scenario is I
don't have devices.
I just want to test something.
And we link that to the regular
check task from Gradle.
So you're going to be limited
to what you can run there.
You're going to be able to run
static analysis like other
FindBugs and all links.
And if you use Robolectric,
well, you can
run them there too.
The second scenario is, I'm a
developer sitting at my desk.
I have my phone connected
to my workstation,
maybe also a tablet.
I want to run something.
So that's what connected
check is.
It will just look for connected
devices, run
everything on it in parallel,
just give you your results.
OK, third scenario is
your build server.
Well here, you shouldn't really
have devices connected
directly to your build server.
Several issues.
First, well, you may have more
than one build server.
So that's a problem.
You're going to enable
a lot more devices.
If you do build in parallel, you
can't run instrumentation
tests that hit the UI in
parallel, because that's just
not going to work.
So we need to have some
sort of queue, right?
So we looked around, and there's
really two different
scenarios there,
sub-scenarios.
So the first one is, you have
a device lab somewhere.
And you have a queue system.
And your build system just
builds something, and then it
gets put in the queue.
And you have devices,
and you test that.
And, well, you're going to get
a remote dashboard, because
it's not going to be your
Jenkins systems
running your tests.
So you'll get a different
dashboard.
But that will work.
So one thing that we think is
important here is that you
don't want Jenkins to, after
your build, say hey, what's
the output?
I grab the output and I upload
it somewhere because Jenkins
doesn't know about all the build
variants that I just
talked about.
So you want to have the build
system, who is aware of that,
actually do the push.
So that whenever you add a new
build variant, or remove one,
you don't have to go
back and configure
your Jenkins instance.
So we created an API.
And we call that test
server APIs.
And it allows you to upload
an APK somewhere.
It's very easy to implement.
And so if you have your
own testing lab, you
can implement it.
If you don't have your own
testing lab, well, there are
services out there
that do that.
Testdroid is one.
AppThwack is one.
Both of them are
on the Sandbox.
So you should go and
talk to them.
And we're going to work with
those guys to make sure that
they create a plugin, and
we integrate with them.
The second scenario is, well,
what if you have [INAUDIBLE]
devices or emulators, it's
generally going to be emulator
that runs directly
and on demand.
So here we have another API.
It's very simple.
We get the list of devices.
And for each device, we connect
to them, which in case
of emulator is really going
to be just starting them.
Then we install, we get the
test, we drop them, and then
we have, actually,
a local result.
And there's different companies
doing that.
One of them is Manimal.
They're here, also,
on the Sandbox.
So you can go and
talk to them.
Or maybe I can show
you, actually.
We worked with those guys,
and we created a plugin.
So let's look at what
that looks like.
So here I have a
sample project.
It's very basic.
I have a build.gradle here.
So we applied the Android plugin
right here and then
their plugin.
So what that does is, basically,
their plugin, upon
being installed, automatically
finds our plugin and says,
hey, I'm implementing
that extension
point, just go there.
And then, because it's a greater
plugin, it can also
have its own DSL.
So here we have a custom DSL
that says, hey, I want to test
on those two devices.
But they have over 50
different emulator
configurations.
And so if you don't provide any
device, it's just going to
say, I want to test
on all of them.
So it's going to get the list
from their server, find the
ones that are compatible with
your application, depending on
your minSDK version and
things like that.
Well, right now, only minSDK
version, but later, ABIs and
things like that.
And it will just run all
the tests in parallel.
So here, for it to be easier,
we're just going to test on
two different ones.
So the first thing I want to
show you is, when you get the
list of tasks, because
we know that there's
this extension point--
so we have here, automatically,
a many more
instrument test method.
And so, every time you have a
new service provider, we have
a new task for it.
But we're not going
to call it.
On your build server, you
would directly do Gradle
device check.
I'm going to do info here.
And so it's going to be build
the application, which
actually doesn't need
to be built.
So it's going to say,
up-to-date, up-to-date,
up-to-date.
And here we start building.
Say, hey, connecting
to that emulator.
And so my device is not starting
any emulator here.
It's actually connecting
in the cloud.
It's starting the
[INAUDIBLE] one.
And then it's going to deploy.
Hey, I have a test
that succeeded.
And it's shutting it down now.
And then I have another
test that succeeded.
And it's done.
And that's it.
I just tested on two different
emulators on the cloud.
It could've been 20,
50 in parallel.
Super easy to do.
And then you just go and you
do open build/reports/in
strumentTests/device--
and you have a report
per provider--
index.html.
And you have your test.
It's tested on those
two devices.
You can look per device.
And it's there.
Super easy to do.
We really wanted to improve.
[APPLAUSE]
XAVIER DUCROHET: So we really
want to improve the experience
of testing for Android.
And there's a lot of things
that go in there.
There's helping you
write tests.
And we need to work on that.
But running them is
a big part of it.
And working with companies
like Manimal.
So again, down on the show
floor, they actually have a
special offer for
I/O attendees.
So you should definitely
go and check them out.
Integrating with third-party
services, or making it easy
for you to integrate with
your own system
internally is super important.
And we want to make sure that
is super easy for you to use
All right, the last thing I
want to talk about is the
built environment.
So we know that, in the past,
we've regularly updated the
tools and somehow broke
your build.
You get a new version of ADT,
and nothing compiles anymore.
And it's a big problem.
And we want to fix that.
We want to make sure that this
doesn't happen again.
And Gradle is really going
to help us do that.
There's four key
points to that.
First, well, you're in charge
of the Gradle version.
And you were already in charge
of the Ant version somewhat,
but Gradle actually--
they increased, they added new
features so quickly compared
to Ant that it's good that
you're in charge.
And they have this feature
called the Wrapper that makes
it super easy for you to really
control the fact that
every developer, everybody build
server, has the same
version of Gradle.
It's a really sleek tool.
Really check it out.
Second point is, you're
in charge of the
version of the plugin.
So you saw in the DSL right at
the beginning how I say, hey,
get the plugin from Maven
Central, and here's it is.
Well, part of the artifact
address is the version number.
When we update a new version,
we're not going to remove the
old version.
So you can always stay
on an older version.
And it's up to you to switch
when you're ready to switch.
The second point is that
probably, that I didn't talk
about also at the beginning.
So the plugin uses some tools,
like APT to compile the
resources, DX to compile the
bytecode into Dalvik.
And it used to be in the SDK
under a component called
Platform Tools.
And there was only one
version of it.
And sometimes, when you update
the tools, it forces you to
update the platform tool, and
so, suddenly, hey, it's
updated under you, and you
don't have a choice.
So here, we moved that out
of the SDK platform tool
component, and we created
a new component
called Build Tools.
And the big point about Build
Tools is it that you can have
many of them in the SDK.
So imagine a case
where you have--
[APPLAUSE]
XAVIER DUCROHET: So imagine a
case where you have an SDK.
You have an old project that
you don't want to migrate,
because it's fine
the way it is.
It's using an old plugin and
an version of Build Tools.
It's not a problem.
You want to start
a new project.
You want to start fresh.
You use the new version
of the plugin.
You use a new version of Build
Tools, and you have two
different projects using two
different tool chains from a
single SDK.
And then finally, the fourth
point is that, well, the IDE I
mentioned that when we talked
about Studio on Wednesday.
The IDE doesn't do
a build anymore.
You import greater projects.
You delegate to greater project
whenever you do build.
So before, when you updated the
ADT, you would get both,
inside the same plugin,
a builder and editors.
Here, Studio is all
about editing, and
debugging, and profiling.
It's not about building
anymore.
So feel free, every time we
release a new version of
Studio or of ADT, when we
integrate Gradle into ADT,
which is coming, feel free
to get the new version.
Because Gradle, it's only when
you change those values in
your build script that you will
force yourself to switch
to a new version of the build.
All right, so this is a very
short introduction to the
build system.
There's a lot of information
online at tools.android.com, a
lot of documentation, and
more details about
configuring the build.
Like I mentioned, the DSL for
the library is very different.
So you should check it out.
We need your feedback, right?
We want to make sure that it's
as flexible as it needs to be
for all of you.
I think we already have a
lot of customization.
But I'm sure there are some
things that we're missing.
And so give us feedback,
try it.
Especially with Studio, anyway,
you have to try it.
So that's why we're
very happy.
And just give us feedback,
FindBug, and we'll do whatever
we can to improve things.
So actually, it looks like I
do have time for questions.
[APPLAUSE]
XAVIER DUCROHET: Thank you.
So I will be after anyway in the
Sandbox upstairs to answer
whatever questions.
But we do have time,
so I guess we
can take some questions.
AUDIENCE: So you mentioned that
I believe you had compile
and release dependencies or
runtime dependencies-- you
guys have different
names for it.
How is android.jar treated?
XAVIER DUCROHET: I'm
sorry, android.jar?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, because it's
like a build-only dependency.
XAVIER DUCROHET: So it's
done automatically.
You don't have to do it.
In your DSL, at the beginning,
when you say compile SDK
version 17, it just picks
the SDK version from 17.
AUDIENCE: So can you add
a hook for that?
Is it possible for you guys
to add a hook for that?
XAVIER DUCROHET: I'm
sorry, do what?
AUDIENCE: Well, some of us are
compiling custom versions of
android.jar.
XAVIER DUCROHET: Umm--
well, you probably
shouldn't be.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: Some of us are.
XAVIER DUCROHET: Yeah.
And we'll have to figure
something out, I guess.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: First, thank you.
It's a lot of stuff.
I have two questions.
One is about library
projects dot AAR.
Do they each have their own
R.java or does the whole lab
have its own R.java?
XAVIER DUCROHET: So AAR has--
I'm sorry.
Can you repeat?
AUDIENCE: So can library
projects
have their own resources?
XAVIER DUCROHET: Yeah,
resources, assets.
So the AAR is a zip file.
In it, you have classes.jar.
That's your compile classes.
It has your manifest, in case
you have activities,
permissions, and things
like that.
It has resource folder, assets
folder, it has a ProGuard
file, in case you have one.
Ultimately, it will have JNI
libraries if you have them,
[INAUDIBLE], whatever.
AUDIENCE: OK, thanks you.
And the second question is
about NDK integration.
XAVIER DUCROHET: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: You had a couple
things there
about x86 and JNI.
XAVIER DUCROHET: So I do mention
the whole x86 and ARM,
and that's the design of it.
But we don't support
the NDK right now.
So that's coming very
soon though.
So you'll be able to
build directly.
Gradle will call
out to the NDK.
It will have a way of
configuring in a build type
which ABI you want to use,
either all three if you want
to do a fat package
or just one.
And then it will call out to
the NDK saying, hey, please
build the ARM version and put
the result here for that build
type, build it for another
ABI, and put it there for
another build type.
And so that's how we're going
to do the filtering.
AUDIENCE: And will that be
integrated into Android Studio
also, the NDK building?
XAVIER DUCROHET: Yes, so it
will be part of Gradle.
So whenever you build with
Gradle, if you say, hey, I
want to build native stuff,
it will build it.
And Studio will technically
not care about it.
At some point, we'll have to add
editing features for them.
That's going to take longer.
But at least you would be able
to edit your files and just to
make it work.
AUDIENCE: So where can
we see details of
what's coming for NDK?
XAVIER DUCROHET: We don't
really have any roadmap
planned at this time.
AUDIENCE: OK.
XAVIER DUCROHET: I mean, we do
have some plans, but we don't
have anything written down.
AUDIENCE: Hi, my name is Mark.
I would like to know that, OK,
so now we have many folders,
like, SRC, JAVA, JNI, RRS,
asset, and so on.
And the merging process
of these
folders, are they different?
Or what I really want to know,
can we have dependencies and
assets, so if we have library
processes with the assets in
it-- right now it's not built
into the final APK--
is that true for the new one,
for the Gradle build?
XAVIER DUCROHET: Yeah, so if
you have assets in your
library that will get packed
into your package.
You can have assets,
per flavor.
Every flavor, every build type,
has its own JAVA code,
its own manifest, it's own
resources, its own assets.
And depending on which flavor
you're building, it just picks
up and merge all of that
together automatically.
And libraries are picked up
automatically and merged.
And it's--
AUDIENCE: Thanks, I waited
a long time for that.
XAVIER DUCROHET: All right.
AUDIENCE: So since you're not
supporting NDK, how about Ant?
Is that still going to be
supported for the time being?
XAVIER DUCROHET: Ant is going
to be, I guess, deprecated.
I would recommend moving
to Gradle as soon
as you're able to.
If you're missing features--
AUDIENCE: You're not
supporting NDK.
XAVIER DUCROHET: Oh support
for the NDK?
AUDIENCE: You just said that
you're not supporting NDK at
this moment.
So the only way to build it--
well, not the only way, but--
XAVIER DUCROHET: Well, right
now, the NDK doesn't build
with Ant either.
It just makes files.
AUDIENCE: Yes, but it's
easy to integrate.
XAVIER DUCROHET: Yes, but
that's not the future.
[LAUGHTER]
XAVIER DUCROHET: It's like, I
mean, we're going to keep the
make files inside
the NDK anyway.
So you can call it manually
if you want.
It's like, the problem with the
Ant stuff is that it's a
mix of, I have some scripting
in the XML, we have some
custom code, because whenever
we have some really complex
logic, like combining all of
those sourceSet, assets, res,
all of that, you can
do that in XML.
So we have custom tasks.
I reimplemented quick if/else
statements in the custom task
to be able to use
it in my XML.
But it's like, it's a mix.
And we pass a lot of things to
the custom task, and then back
to the XML, and back to another
custom task, it's just
a fucking mess.
It's just, we can't
maintain that.
And I'm happy to let it be
whatever it is when it was
switched to Gradle, but we're
not going to improve it.
It's not going to work
from an IDE.
It's deprecated.
It will be deprecated.
But I mean, it's open source.
Take it, make sure that you have
a good version, if you
really want to maintain it.
But we're not going to
keep maintaining it.
The goal of this build system
is to have a single one that
works everywhere.
So I'm not going to keep
maintaining also another one--
although right now I am.
But when we switch to 1.0,
we're not anymore.
AUDIENCE: Hi [INAUDIBLE].
My name's William.
I've been using Maven to
build up until now.
So it looks like I've got to
change the way I'm thinking
about things.
One of things that Maven does
really well is you can go and
release your APK at the end.
And it handles all of the
versioning and makes sure
everything works all right.
How's that going to
work with Gradle?
XAVIER DUCROHET: Wait, sorry,
can you repeat that?
AUDIENCE: Gradle doesn't seem to
have the release mechanism
that Maven does where, when you
want to go and release a
version of your APK, it handles
the versioning,
interacts with your source
control mechanism, does all
the build for you, updates
source control, publishes to
your artifcat repositories,
et cetera.
XAVIER DUCROHET: Yeah, that's
probably more like a question
for Gradle itself
than our plugin.
You know Gradle, where they
have a Sandbox, and when I
take questions, there will be
people from Gradleware.
Because it's more
like the whole
workflow behind releasing.
And Gradle I'm sure
supports that.
We'll do that upstairs.
We'll take that question
upstairs.
AUDIENCE: All right, the other
one is, APK libs, which are
pretty common imports now--
XAVIER DUCROHET: Yes, so the
Maven plugin will switch to
AAR format.
I'm looking to supporting
APK lib.
But I'm not sure if that's
going to happen or not.
But they're switching to AAR.
And I know some libraries
are going to
publish to AAR already.
So I talk to Jack
[? Wharton ?].
[INAUDIBLE]
at some point are going
to distribute AAR.
So you'd be able to use that.
AUDIENCE: So we'll be able to,
for our libraries we intend on
publishing, we'll be able to
create an AAR as an output?
XAVIER DUCROHET: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: All right,
cool, thanks.
XAVIER DUCROHET: All right,
thank you, so I'll be upstairs
if you have more questions,
feel free to
come and talk to me.
[APPLAUSE]